blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman welcome everybody hope
everybody celebrating thanksgiving has a
uh good thanksgiving planned um we will
talk on the bonus show today what are my
plans what are producer pat's plans
producer pat's plans are much more
interesting than mine uh he he will he
will tell us all about it a few stories
that i did want to go over with you guys
this story has gotten quite a bit of
attention uh multiple conservatives have
quit fox news over
what they say is the
increasing propaganda
particularly from tucker carlson and
it's interesting for what they say and
it's also interesting for what they
don't say and you'll see what i mean in
a moment
this is about jonah goldberg and stephen
hayes who have resigned from fox news
protesting the irresponsible voice of
people like tucker carlson
hayes and goldberg announced sunday
night that they have resigned from fox
the pair wrote in a blog post for the
dispatch their online home that tucker
carlson's patriot purge propaganda film
was the last straw
fox news still does real reporting and
there are still responsible
conservatives providing valuable opinion
and analysis they wrote but the voices
of the responsible are being drowned out
by the irresponsible and carlson is the
case in point
cnn and other news outlets outlets
described how patriot purge is
disturbing evidence of right-wing
radicalization complete with january 6
denialism and paranoid descriptions of a
new war on terror targeting republicans
with references to guantanamo bay and
images of waterboarding now this is
interesting for a few different reasons
first of all the resignation came sunday
night
in advance of the one hour propaganda
documentary produced by tucker carlson
about the kyle rittenhouse case
and the full interview that tucker
carlson did with kyle rittenhouse which
we covered yesterday which are
incredible propaganda pieces total and
full propaganda uh lionizing and making
a hero out of kyle rittenhouse
portraying him even as an expert on
things like prosecutorial misconduct
self-defense the fbi i mean completely
out of this world propaganda so it's
interesting that
it was the patriot purge thing that that
was sort of like the last straw
now it's interesting where these people
draw the line
um
goldberg and haze are certainly more
along the lines of what we might call
um i i hate to use the term like normal
conservatives but sort of more
traditional conservatives in the line of
like mitt romney and liz cheney in fact
mentioning liz cheney's interesting
because liz cheney even tweeted out a
thank you to goldberg and hayes for
calling out the lies on fox
from that patriot purge
propaganda piece
including the lies related to the 2020
election so that that's interesting
because that's clearly a contingent
but it's interesting where people draw
the line
because patriot purge is over the top
but fox has been radicalizing viewers
forever in many different ways and in
the months of uh uh the aftermath of the
2020 election
they were giving voice to absolutely
wacky conspiracy theorists with
completely fact-free views on the
election
and on and on and on so i don't want to
belittle the fact that goldberg and
hayes said this is as far as we're going
and this is too much and we've got to
leave that's fine
it's interesting because and it's
strange because the big picture of what
fox news is and what fox news does
really hasn't changed actually for a
very long time to be fair
uh tucker has been particularly off the
deep end lately with the anti-vac stuff
the written house stuff
etc so mentioning tucker is is sensible
that that certainly makes sense uh the
other thing about this is um
they're likely to be replaced with
wackier people and this is one of the
things where
when donald trump during covid uh during
his um
calling it administration of koba
doesn't even make sense when he was
president during the pandemic
and donald trump started slamming
anthony fauci and increasingly people
were asking why doesn't fauci quit
why why stay in this situation
we said and maybe fauci also said i
don't remember i'm just kind of going
going from memory
that if he leaves he may well be
replaced with a yes person of some kind
rather than someone who's going to
insist on telling us what the science
actually is and along those same lines i
don't expect that goldberg and hayes are
going to be replaced on fox news by more
sensible people and that's always a
question that comes up
when someone has had enough with
something like fox news and they say i'm
taking myself out of it
often they get replaced with even more
radical voices and that well may happen
but we're going to watch it and it's
always interesting to see where do they
draw the line jonah goldberg and stephen
hayes drawing the line at the patriot
purge film from sunday
and
it's not a crazy place to draw the line
it was a completely whacked out film
um but it will be different for everyone
and of course that same film
many conspiracy theorists seeing it and
saying
now we have fox as well we got him
they're now with us and that's obviously
very very scary
when we talk about consequences for
perpetuating the lie that donald trump
actually won the 2020 election that joe
biden actually stole the 2020 election
one
group of people that participated in
that is attorneys attorneys filing bogus
lawsuits and we have some nice news
a judge has ordered pro-trump attorneys
who brought a frivolous election fraud
case to pay more than 180
000
to defendants that they sued caitlyn
polance writing about this for cnn
two lawyers who went to court to claim
voter fraud after the 2020 election must
pay nearly 180 grand to the defendants
the judge wrote that their lawsuit aimed
to manipulate gullible members of the
public and foment public unrest these
are attorneys you may not
be familiar with this is not lynn wood
rudy giuliani sydney powell jenna ellis
this is attorneys gary fielder and
ernest john walker they're going to have
to pay attorney's fees of 50 grand to
facebook now known as meta
63 dollars to dominion voting systems
sixty three thousand dollars to the
non-profit center for tech and civil
life
six thousand to the state of
pennsylvania five thousand to the state
of michigan
the judge
near writer wrote in his order
they need to take responsibility for
their misconduct i believe
that rather than a legitimate use of the
legal system to seek redress for
redressable grievances this lawsuit has
been used to manipulate gullible members
of the public and foment public unrest
to that extent this lawsuit has been an
abuse of the legal system and an
interference with the machinery of
government for all these reasons i feel
that a significant sanctions award is
merited this is fantastic
it's one thing to see them laughed out
of court
told as they were with was it 63
lawsuits
that there's no merit
that it's not going to go forward that
the judge is going to put a stop to it
that is good
but at a certain point
if it doesn't hit them
in the pocketbook
proverbial pocketbook
it doesn't really disincentivize them
from doing this again and we have a
legal system where if there's merit they
will they will be allowed to carry this
forward there was absolutely no merit
here
the lawsuit from late december was an
attempt to create a class action
challenge on behalf of voters including
eight plaintiffs
narrator wrote a scathing 68-page
opinion condemning the lawsuit the
plaintiffs had no lawyers or experts
able to support their claims of switched
votes and government conspiracies the
judge noted calling the lawsuit itself
one enormous conspiracy theory
you will also recall that in august a
federal judge in michigan sanctioned
pro-trump lawyers sydney powell and lynn
wood who i mentioned earlier and other
attorneys ordering them to reimburse the
attorney's fees that the city of detroit
and michigan state officials paid the
judge said the lawyers who worked on
trump-aligned lawsuits seeking to
challenge election results had engaged
in litigation practices that were
abusive and in turn sanctionable these
people have to be held accountable
they have to be held accountable because
they are going to do this again and we
don't have to
um
guess at whether they will do it again
they're telling us that they will do it
again they told us before
the virginia gubernatorial race
that it looked like there was already
fraud glenn younkin ultimately won but
if glenn younkin had lost they were
going to do it again we know that they
have been explicit in saying we're going
to keep going with this they don't
really want solutions to the problem
they claim exists
they want to use claims of voter fraud
as a cudgel as a mallet of sorts
to beat the public over the head when an
election doesn't actually go their way
and uh there need to be consequences and
this this is a excellent decision we'll
see if they actually pay the money i
want to remind everybody of a couple
things we are going to be off tomorrow
thursday as well as friday for the
thanksgiving federal holiday here in the
united states i know that
most of our american viewers know about
this but i always get dozens and dozens
of emails from around the world david
sir where are you
and uh it is thanksgiving we will be off
for the rest of the week
also we've scheduled the next david
pakman show viewer town hall it's gonna
be on december 14th at 6 p.m eastern
time it will be number one open to
anybody who wants to call in
but priority will be given to our
website members so you can get yourself
signed up at joinpakman.com if you want
a better chance to talk to me on the
14th the entire event will stream live
for whoever wants to watch it it will be
exclusively on the pacman live youtube
channel that's
youtube.compacmanlive it won't be on our
main youtube channel it won't be on
twitch it won't be on facebook it'll be
exclusively on the pacman live youtube
channel so that's december 14th and of
course you can sign up on our website
joinpakman.com become a member and as a
member you will also get access to
today's bonus show in which i will tell
you my thanksgiving plans very boring
but producer pat will tell us his
thanksgiving plans very very exciting
all right we'll take a quick break and
be back right after this
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily made possible by viewers and
listeners like you through our
membership program you can sign up at
joinpacman.com
members get instant access to the daily
bonus show an extra show we produce just
for you you also get commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
priority handling during our viewer town
halls the next of which is going to be
on
december 14th at 6 00 pm eastern time
let's hear from some people in the
audience because of the shortened
thanksgiving week we're doing our calls
today instead of on the friday show we
take calls via discord davidpakman.com
discord let's first today
speak
with
gary
from california gary you're on the air
what's going on
hmm
gary
from california
you're on the air
gary we're hearing some pops coming from
you are you able to unmute and talk to
me
uh yeah can you hear me
yes i can what's going on
um okay uh sorry if there's stuff in the
background but i'm kind of new to the
whole politics thing i was wondering if
there's any primer that i can read that
would get me into like
uh social democracy or keynesian
economic theory
oh uh
okay so wow um yes there are tons of
books on those topics i i don't i don't
know that i have specific
recommendations but i as a great place
to start
um
go to the wiki page for any of these
topics and i'm i know anybody can edit
wiki so before everybody
jumps down my throat
go down to the sources where you will
see source materials and that's always a
great place to start a lot of these wiki
pages have dozens or even hundreds of
references that include articles and
books that you can read that's a good
place to start i i don't know of any
specific book on social democracy
necessarily uh but that that's where i
would recommend you start
all right thank you
all right gary from california uh thanks
very very much for the uh call
let's continue let's go next to vince
from wisconsin vince you're on the air
can you hear me yes i can
oh great uh how you doing david i'm
doing well thanks vince
all right so i just had two questions i
had a brief question and a longer
question all right and my longer
question is uh what are your thoughts on
attorney general garland's performance
so far i don't know that he's done
enough one way or the other to really
evaluate his performance um he has
put out some memos memoranda as we might
call them
um saying that
he's going to be looking into this or or
exploring that uh i just don't think we
have enough data points i mean he's been
in his job months and i i don't know
that i have anything substantive to say
about his performance this way at this
point in time
yeah he seems pretty milk close to me i
mean he's he's not he's refused to he's
still sitting on uh charges for uh
obstruction of justice charges for trump
he's
representing him for god's sake in that
lawsuit uh i believe it's eg and carol
isn't he was who accused him of rape
yeah and uh defamation lawsuit
i mean that's going forward as far as i
know
oh really yeah good that's good are you
rolling dice in the background by the
way
oh no i'm sorry i'm sorry oh i bet
no i'm not rolling guys oh cool but uh
so sorry about the noise but my uh my
second question is uh would you consider
uh interviewing brian tyler cohen at any
point
um
i i mean i don't know that it's for our
show usually we don't interview people
who just have like other channels like
mine but i would definitely do a
collaboration with him of some kind like
on a live stream i think it'd be a
better fit for that but like on our show
you know i don't tend to interview like
sam cedar or fahren cousins or that type
of thing on the podcast but i would do a
collaboration with him for sure
okay all right thanks david all right my
pleasure uh thanks for the call very
much appreciate it
let's go next to
let's go to cliff from seattle cliff
you're on the air
oh hi can you hear me yes i can
awesome oh cool um i didn't really
expect you
called on uh i've been a big fan of
yours for a bit now um thank you all
right
that's curious so we've i live in
washington state as you can guess um our
last election the one that uh elected
joe biden we also reelected jay inslee
and um rather immediately uh his big
contender the republican candidate um
started calling for uh saying was voter
fraud there was massive voter fraud
and that didn't seem to really go
anywhere in this state like it wasn't
taken seriously by our um
people in this state he uh lost by about
i think it was 60 percent to 40 percent
or so
um
but i'm really concerned that i see this
being the tactic the standing tactic
that uh republicans are going to use
continuously do you
absolutely and i've spoken about this
before yeah jay inslee defeated lauren
kulp by 13 points in 2020 it was 50
basically 56 to 43 57 to 43 and there
were a few attempts from republicans to
push the voter fraud thing it went
nowhere because number one there's
absolutely no factual basis for it and
number two you know a 13 and a half
point loss it's going to be very very
difficult to over overcome in any
serious way but as i've said before this
is going to be it's almost becoming a
meme at this point which is if we win it
was fine and if we lose it was voter
fraud we saw them lay the groundwork for
it earlier this month in virginia
because remember before the election for
the virginia governor between yunkan and
mcauliffe you started to see like there
was a republican state senator trump and
others saying looks like the democrats
are stealing it again yunkan ended up
winning they didn't say a word about it
anymore
we won why had there's no fraud we won
so it's a very dangerous precedent and
you're absolutely right
yeah and um i don't know i'm just
concerned of like what that's going to
do from
how to combat it from the people that's
that
you know agree with it and believe it
and
how we can
neutralize that threat from the public
see here's the thing
for a lot of these people
they don't literally believe there was
voter fraud
they believe that if you want to
demonstrate your bona fides and
commitment and devotion to the team
you say that you believe there was voter
fraud and it's a way that you virtue
signal
that you're part of the team
i think that for some of these people
they don't actually believe it they just
say that they believe it it doesn't
actually make it less dangerous though
yeah i i agree it's
i've got some family that uh agree with
there was fraud and such and it's uh
really
frustrating
do you think they literally believe it
or that they believe it's what you have
to say to prove you're on the right team
my impression is that they believe it
but i guess i haven't really considered
that maybe it is a uh just another
virtual virtue signaling from the right
and either way it's disgusting and
dangerous i think you we're on the same
page about that
gotcha yeah well i'm a big fan of the
show and i really appreciate you taking
my call i appreciate it thank you so
much for calling in yeah it's an
important time it's part of this like
they see themselves as waging a war
and part of that is you've got to show
you're on the team and so they say a lot
of things they may not they may not
literally believe but they might but
they might let's go next to eddie from
south bend is that is that south bend
indiana
uh yeah that's right can you hear me all
right i can eddie what's going on
so i have possibly your first ever
multiple choice call okay so
on a scale of one to five one being a
super softball question and five being
what many are calling the greatest
indictment of the david backman show
so what would you like on a scale of one
to five
like in other words you have five
different questions that i can choose
from
yeah number three is more like i guess a
comment but yeah pretty much let's not
go with that let's go with a four i'll
take a tough question but not like the
toughest
okay so
uh you know i've been uh going back in
your earlier videos looking at
some of your earlier opinions something
i haven't talked about in a while is
sort of representation and identity
politics okay so to some degree there is
like
i would argue an importance to these
sorts of things and i have a
a story if you want it from that uh from
an experiment my friend did but in any
case i guess the question would be uh to
what degree would you sacrifice policy
for identity
in politics what do you ever mean by
that i'd need to what's an example of
that can you give me an example of what
it would mean to sacrifice policy for
identity
so let's say uh for instance like the uh
warren versus bernie
right so warren was less good on policy
than bernie
but it would be you know a first woman
presidential candidate
the example i have initially was a
friend of mine did this experiment when
she was a teacher in st louis and this
was during the riots down there she had
all of her students in their fourth
grade class draw a scientist
and every one of them drew a an older
white male okay
and all the students were black and not
one of them drew a black person and they
were wondering why and they were like oh
we don't that's not something i can do
and they they weren't aware of
any black scientists so
to what degree would you be willing to
give in on some policies if any
for the sake of you know giving
representation to unrepresented groups
so um
i mean my view on this really hasn't
changed which is i i care about policy
and
not identity
in terms of making decisions
but i still recognize the importance of
identity
in our understanding of the world and so
my opposition to identity politics has
been
you can't use identity as a cudgel to
silence people
to delegitimize voices and so that's why
i was for example so against when the
women's march said jewish women weren't
intersectional enough to be on the
leadership i was completely against that
i found that vile in my analysis of the
2020 democratic candidates i didn't care
about identity at all i only cared about
policy etc at the same time
um
there is no understating
the importance and value and inspiration
of for example
we now have a female vice president for
the first time and it's the first you
know there's all these other deca i
don't even know all the category i i'm
so out of the identity game that i don't
even know all the all the categories
that kamal harris is part of i think is
it is there the native american or
asian you know all these different
things okay um there's no question
that for young girls
and
young minority girls or all minority
people whatever um
there's value in seeing
that
there is now an individual that checks
certain boxes that for the first time is
in this role that there's no need to
minimize that what i'm against is using
identity as a cudgel or as a weapon uh
and i don't know if that answers your
question but i think it's a complicated
topic
no i agree it's it's super complicated i
think that's a that's about where i'm at
as well i was kind of curious because in
some of the videos i had seen
it seemed you were very much so like
against identity politics but thanks for
the clarification and like you know yeah
i'm against identity i'm against
identity politics but i'm in favor of
recognizing the value of identity and
what it brings to our conversations of
things
that makes sense
all right my friend thank you very much
for the call i appreciate it
um let's see what else here
um
we uh by the way don't don't use my name
on our discord server you're gonna get
banned for that
um so use use a real name don't don't
say your name is david pakman that's not
we don't allow that
let's try zach from orlando zack you're
on the air
zach from orlando you're on the air
hey danny can you hear me just barely
zach go ahead
uh yeah so my question is uh
as someone who considers himself pretty
far left i look at countries like
uh denmark or norway sweden canada et
cetera as countries that i would like
the united states to kind of emulate
um and i have a lot of conservative
family members i'm like the only one
that's even left i guess okay um and i
never hear them talk about any other
country in a good way i was wondering
are there countries that the united
conservatives uh
praise or think are good
you know i mean you you really have to
ask them but what's really really funny
is that
for these
kind of hardcore christian republicans
the countries that most match their
moral values are radical islamist
countries
that have
you know many of them want a christian
version
of what many of these muslim countries
have
and so it's often what they envision as
ideal is like saudi arabia etc even
though they claim not to like those
countries and it's a very interesting
contrast
but you'd really have to ask them i
don't know what countries they like a
lot of them say they like what uh
duterte has done and cleaning things up
and whatever you know we're talking
about a dictator here um you'd really
have to ask them but there's some pretty
serious hypocrisy there for sure
of course yeah well thank you very much
for picking on me i didn't think i'd get
called on i appreciate it my pleasure
great to speak to you we're gonna take a
very very quick break if you're holding
to talk to me don't hang up because
we're gonna go right back to the phones
momentarily stand by
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's get back to the phone's
last show before thanksgiving we're
going to hear from a bunch of different
people um davidpakman.com
discord is the place where you can
contact me
um let's go right into it and see what's
on people's minds
let's go to
is it borac or baruch from miami florida
from miami you're on the air please
unmute and you'll be able to talk to me
and last chance for borah from miami
florida last opportunity to unmute
yourself
and that's too bad let's go to matt from
northern california matt you're on the
air next
hey check one two david can you hear me
you're coming in loud and clear matt
david thanks man i appreciate you taking
the call
so
as stated i live in rural northern
california we're about two hours north
of san francisco and so is that like
humboldt county pot
area uh just south um i'm part of the
emerald triangle mendocino county
actually because that'll be mendo humble
and trinity county got it um
you know it a little bit uh
so
from where i'm sitting it's just this
really interesting nexus of
rural
sort of urban resentment um mixed in
with this infusion of kind of back to
land uh uh berkeley liberal um
organic
uh
kind of culture clash and
with that i
the
specific political moment we're in i
think is this
confusing identity crisis for especially
like rural
satellite counties of the bay area in
northern california there's there's a
lot of resentment towards um
san francisco uh you know the the rash
of organized thefts recently the these
the covey lockdowns um but
also there's this kind of libertarian uh
common denominator in the resentment
that's uh despite sort of some trappings
of maybe some trumpism they're generally
pro-gay marriage they're pro-cannabis
um but then sort of on the other
political
side they're pro-firearm ownership so
you know i guess i'm just kind of
curious about your perspective david on
what democratic messaging can do to
start letting these i i think there's a
huge uh place in the democratic party
platform for a lot of these ideas but
there's some sort of communication
breakdown and disconnect and i'd love to
know your thoughts on messaging have we
given up on these populations is there
an approach that you could see an inroad
to get them considering the blue ticket
well i hate to say this because it's
such an important issue but if you are
you're talking about strategy which is
great i love it
uh if we want to talk about strategy
you probably don't want to attack guns
and gun owners i mean it's it's it's
crazy to say it but as we've looked at
in a number of studies when the topic of
guns is a factor in elections it tends
to be good for republicans and bad for
democrats and it serves as a
disincentive for people to vote for
democrats so
i'm the ultimate pragmatist i'm not
saying gun safety doesn't matter i'm not
saying we don't have a massive gun
safety issue in the u.s we do
but
after the sandy hook shooting
with barack obama being president had
the house and senate still weren't able
to get universal background checks
passed even with like 88 or 90 american
support for it that doesn't mean i'm
saying we give up on the issue at all
maybe it means
you deal with it at the state level or
i'm not sure
but for the group you're talking about
where gun ownership is an issue
don't
alienate people
by talking about guns and making it
central make economic issues central
cetera and again i i know people will be
mad at me and they'll say david but the
gun issue matters i agree it matters
but i think it's bad strategy and it
only serves to mobilize republicans and
others who might otherwise vote for
democrats but don't want to because of
the perception that they're hostile to
guns so i think that's how i would start
making inroads with the group that
you're describing that
david can i ask a follow-up question yes
of course
regarding the specific issue of cannabis
and the democratic party
we've found this really strange
stalemate that's emerged regarding the
federal legalization of cannabis and
recently my understanding is there's
been some talk on um
the beltway of even republicans starting
to come out in support of the federal
legalization yes and i guess i have a
concern that where
you know the democrats could have put
that feather in their cap and the cans
gotten kicked long enough that you know
maybe maybe the republicans
will pick up that can and put that
feather in their caps well there's two
sides to that there's two sites that so
you're rightly pointing out hey you know
what democrats could have done more on
federal marijuana maybe not legalization
but at least decriminalization before
republicans start working on it and
saying we want that too the thing is i
don't know that without republican help
democrats would really have been able to
get it done so i actually am not sure
about that but i do think that
increasingly um
at minimum decriminalization is is
becoming more and more bipartisan which
is a great thing i don't care who's in
favor of it let's get it done
thank you david i appreciate your
thoughts my pleasure there's matt from
northern california
with a very powerful phone call coming
in
let's go um
oh i don't know let's try mike from
massachusetts mike you're on the air
hey anybody can hear me yes i can
glad to be back um called in last week
we had a good talk uh
had a question regarding kind of like
the
larger scheme like not so much larger
scheme larger scope of like the future
of the united states uh
so
we've seen over the last you know 20
years maybe a little bit more that
there is a
slow but steady general trend towards
not just like diversification of the
population um but also just like it's
like a little more
younger generations as they come up to
be a voting age because tend to be more
liberal more progressive than previous
generations and
overall they're slowly gaining ground
but what we've also seen is that
as as that as that builds up
the
hostility and extremity of
you know the right wing and you know
maybe some people more willing to take
action against what they perceive to be
unethical or immoral people and policies
also seems to be strengthening as well
and i guess my question is do you see a
point where
like do you see a point where this small
but dangerous contingent of the right
because reaches a point where they see
like they are ultimately going to lose
the culture war they're going to lose
like the
like the overall
where the country swings in terms of
politics and just
there where they ultimately reach a
point where they just say we have to at
least in their minds we have to save the
country and actually take action like
they've been talking about for a while
when do you think there's a point coming
of that i would go further i think it's
already started but for now
there aren't that many of them that are
just willing to willy-nilly go and be
violent yet i think a lot of them are
doing the violent rhetoric
i think a lot of them see themselves as
at a certain point we will have to go
and become violent in the real world
some of them have but yeah i think that
it's an absolutely legitimate concern
and when you look at long-term
demographic trends
um
things are changing and short of killing
people which i'm against and think is
disgusting
there's a question as to how are they
going to be able to resist it or push
back against it and i think they're
going to become more radicalized i think
they're going to become more insular a
lot of this rhetoric has gone totally
mainstream i mean remember the clips of
tucker carlson saying on fox news
immigrants make the country dirtier and
poorer and stuff like that so yes i
don't think it's hyperbolic to be
worried that they're going to go even
crazier as these
changes continue to happen in the united
states and it's it's very scary
so a follow-up question if i may um
so we've seen a couple countries that
used to be
like solid democracies and now are only
ostensibly democracies essentially our
autocracies uh the two prime examples in
my mind right now are and maybe there's
more but the two prime are poland and
belarus
um
now
i don't know the intrigue i don't know
the
careful details of their constitutions
what kind of checks and balances they
ever had in place and whatnot obviously
that those could cause differences but
i mean
do you see
do you see something like what's
happened in
poland
theoretically possible here in the
united states
the degree to which it's happening i
think one party i think belarus maybe is
a better example but it's not
it's not a hypothetical in the sense
that the u.s for the first time a few
days ago we covered the story on tuesday
was added to the list of uh backsliding
democracies for the first time ever
oh i missed that story that's
disconcerting to know it's happening
it's happening now unfortunately and
what we mean by backsliding democracy is
a slide towards authoritarianism so it's
not sadly it's not a hypothetical it's
actually happening and the question is
how far will it go obviously i hope it
doesn't go as far as it's gone in
belarus
but uh that is that is happening already
and it's uh horrifying
one more and then i promise i'll let you
move on i know you got a lot of people
waiting um
if that were to happen
do you see
do you see a possibility where
the united states as in like the 50
states no longer exists down the road
and i don't mean like they've torn
they've torn themselves apart from war i
mean
if something like what happens in
belarus as you just said possibly
happens here and we continue down this
backsliding democracy path
um
do you think that certain states that
like say new england in the northeast or
maybe the west coast
attempt to leave
and get away from this backsliding
democracy or do you think that the
or do you think that whoever is trying
to take control
in an
authoritarian kind of way
forces their hand to stay you know
my view on that is
these are essentially random guesses
humans are so bad at making that type of
prediction which is why why i say you
know when trump would say at the state
of the union the us will never be a
socialist country
never is a really long time and uh
historically nations fail
things that are completely inconceivable
take place i have absolutely no idea on
that and i'm not going to pretend to
really have an educated guess because i
think we just don't know anything's
possible
okay fair enough um
all right i appreciate your time i'm
sure a lot of people are waiting to call
in so uh i'm sure i'll be calling it
again and have a good thanksgiving all
right thanks mike likewise mike from
massachusetts with a number of important
questions
let's go next uh where are we gonna go
next let's go to uh let's go to matt
from arizona matt i'm gonna be down in
your neck of the woods very soon
matt from arizona you're on the air
i'm good right
that's you
okay i'm so sorry uh bad connect
um all right david so i'm jumping my
question um
i want to utilize your
master degree
i want to
try and pick your brain
you know a lot of the issues in the
country
have to do with
money
money is a human concept to me
that we created
that we can get rid of if we want to
obviously it's not going anywhere it
creates great structure it creates um
social you know
society
we have so much waste
every year billions billions pounds
wasted food wasted resources wasted
anything
if we could
we could make sure that everybody is
doing well
and and is well off to me i could be
wrong
um but for you using your master degree
what would you say as far as you know
um
the debt and deficit all human created
we can get rid of we can erase it
basically
like who do we owe we have a debt who do
we owe one point
however many trillions
like i i just want to know
your
thought process on that so
you're putting together a few different
issues all of which are big one is the
concept of money
two is hunger and food waste
three is debt and deficit
i'm not sure i totally know exactly what
you want me to weigh in on necessarily
are you saying can't we just say we
don't owe anybody any money or you're
saying just
digitally alter the money supply to
create the amount we owe and then
immediately pay it off or what
definitely not the latter definitely not
that like i understand you know
inflation and all that but what i'm
saying is
money is human created yes so
you know who do we owe like if we could
just make sure that everybody is not
going and starving like there's
literally humans in america but hold on
how does the hunger issue relate to the
who do we owe issue i'm not an i don't
know that i understand the connection it
had to be do do more like around you
know it this really opened my eyes
around pandemic time the heart of the
pandemic food lines in america yeah um
you know sending out stimulus checks to
make sure people you know don't go
hungry
um you know we could just be giving
people food or we could just be
making sure people have a house to live
in yes or don't agree
so
you know we have the resources yes we
have
you know um
everything that a human would need and
accommodate every human on the planet at
the same time yes so you know like we
have
all these issues but they're human
created issues like i don't
yeah all right matt listen you're
bringing up important issues i'm not
actually sure that there's really a
question for me to answer there so i'm
gonna let you go
but very important you've identified
important issues and i think they are
issues that we should be looking into
very strongly for lack of a better term
let's try andy in nebraska next andy
what is your question today you can jump
right into it oh wow uh hey um
i've got kind of a lighthearted question
for you um
just about right-wing media
um sorry it's a little disorienting to
see you in discord versus
your well
edited audio on youtube
um
it's about the gut field show
um because i think you mentioned at one
point that you've actually
corresponded with gut field greg gutfeld
yes i've exchanged some twitter dms with
him yeah
so he
i the the show is i i don't think most
of your viewers um
experience
much of fox news like i came onto this
show when i was at work um
i work as like a
i work on on long shifts
so it was a late night and the gutfield
show came on like i you know it was a
normal fox
montage of of shows
and then the gutfield show came on and
it was just this odd
unusual paradox of like
trying to be a late night show
wow
yeah it's also got it's like a comedy
show andy did you have a question for me
today
yeah i was just curious on your thoughts
of that and fox news because the the
gutfield show is just
fascinating to me yeah the joe the show
is a joke we've talked about how it
tries to be a comedy show and it fails
it's not funny
and it tries to be a news show and it
fails and it's not a news show it's a
very very strange amalgam of different
things andrew yang who was on this show
recently was recently on the gutfeld
show and it was very strange i think
that fox news has no idea what to do
with that show and so they're kind of
feeling around in the dark and nothing
really is working so it'll be curious to
see
whether that show even survives and
that's something we're going to be
following up on all right everybody
that's all the time i had today for
calls we're going to take a break and go
through some of your emails and other
things
we will take calls again and i look
forward to speaking to more of you
coming up very very soon
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright let's get into
this week's mailbag if you want to
participate you can email info
davidpakman.com remember that we do get
hundreds of emails every day we feature
about eight to ten so please please
please with peace and love don't get mad
if yours doesn't make it on uh let's
jump right in to one that is horrible
unfortunately uh really really bad stuff
why do jews keep getting expelled asks h
why were you people
expelled from 109 countries if you did
nothing wrong isn't that a bit strange
if you really think it over if i got
kicked out 109 times from every shop in
the area
at what point should i recognize i'm
doing something wrong not blaming all
jews david
but certainly you people are doing
something wrong there's no anti-semitism
from me
my friends are jewish but at what point
do we stop pretending that all jews are
innocent just asking questions this my
friends is a bonafide bonafide classic
anti-semite
and i have jewish friends
uh do i really need to say more about
that one i'm feeling like the answer is
no so i won't let's continue
a sad message from brady
brady from indiana says hey david my
family and i are in a bit of a situation
all of my family have been lifetime
republicans but despite that they're all
vaccinated that's good but my sister is
hesitant and refusing to get it due to
misinformation she believes the usual
propaganda surrounding vaccine
misinformation and is even thinking
about taking ivor mektin even though
we've told her the dangers we've tried
talking her out talking to her about it
but it always ends up in a fighter
argument and i'm kind of at a loss she's
even thinking about quitting her job due
to the mandates it's also hard on the
family because we usually never argue
over stuff like this do you have
suggestions or advice appreciate it love
the show keep up the great work if you
could not show my email if you cover
this that would be great of course of
course of course we are not showing your
email address we never would um listen
here's the um
here's the the thing
i keep going back to the socratic method
of questioning
which is
presumably her beliefs about the vaccine
being bad
and ivor mechtin being good
are coming
all
from sources to some degree
that she has a similar relationship to
she's chosen some media sources that say
the truth about the vaccine which she
doesn't believe
and yet she's chosen some media sources
that say things about ivermectin which
she does believe
and so often what i've heard from other
viewers is
when you explain to them
you're trusting sources on ivermectin
with the same arbitrary nature with with
your with which you're not trusting
sources about the vaccine if you get
them to come to the realization that can
be useful but it's tough it's very very
tough i don't know
um
that i have real advice beyond that but
let us know how it goes and i'm sorry
you're in that situation
jeffrey wrote to me
and said david i think sometimes you can
be hilarious when you said yesterday i
don't know many race car drivers and you
said butch earnhardt i literally laughed
out loud i don't agree with 90 of what
you say but i watch your show every day
and you make me laugh sometimes keep up
the good work thanks for streaming the
written house trial even though i'm sure
it cost you in the long run yes we are i
appreciate the kind words we are now
unbanned
from twitch
we were originally banned for 30 days
due to a gory exhibit that was displayed
on twitch during our written house
stream
they after 11 days with no explanation
unbanned us and we're back on twitch and
have been streaming there this week so
it's all
it's all very opaque but at the end of
the day we're glad to be back
mark wrote in about the
january 6th alleged trump rioter who has
fled to belarus entering the country
illegally and now asking for asylum
mark says
american in belarus not a traitor david
it's mark from germany i know the gop as
well as trump and his supporters love
using the terms treason and trader
whenever it's politically convenient
with trump often talking about the good
old days when people were executed for
treason despite trump never referring i
think means never referring to a real
case of treason i'm now curious whether
the political right will call the
capital attacker who's avoiding justice
by illegally entering and seeking asylum
in belarus a traitor too
in my opinion this is a perfect example
of treason if we follow the usual right
wing narrative of course
the people saying law and order the
people saying due process the people
saying all those things
uh should be saying wait a second
the trump rioter who fled to belarus
was charged
under the law
was being afforded due process is
wrongly claiming that he's going to be
tortured and all that the the
prosecution is illegitimate and has
decided to flee
and illegally enter a different country
they're not saying it because they don't
actually care their principles are only
their principles as far as they're
convenient to them and when the
principles are no longer convenient they
abandon them but of course mark from
germany is 100 correct
this is kind of funny every once in a
while i get an email
that makes me wonder whether i've lost
my mind colin wrote to me
when i asked last week about can you
help me find the show in which i did an
alex jones impression and colin says i
think the caller is referencing your
nick nixon impression from a few days
back unless i have completely lost my
mind i have not done a nixon impression
on this program at least for years
maybe never
and when i see this like from colin who
says the caller is referring to your
nixon impression
i start to wonder whether i've lost my
mind but we checked we looked i
definitely didn't do a nixon impression
i don't know what it's all about but
it's interesting
brett wrote in about covid boosters and
says hey david considering how many
america considering many americans
receive their second covet shot in april
and may
and it appears we need a booster shot at
six months should we expect a rise in
breakthrough cases over the next months
well we don't have to wonder brett we
are seeing it we are seeing a
significant increase in cases in the
united states now i just got my third
dose a week and a half ago
and i'm glad that i did
the
question has been is it every six months
or does the third dose provide longer
protection so far we have good looking
data from israel which seems to say with
a third shot
the protection lasts longer it doesn't
seem to start to wane at six months now
that's what it seems like right now
the virus can evolve it can change etc
and then a lot of these
beliefs can change but right now
cases are going up and what's really
crazy is there are more people in the us
right now getting third shots
than getting first shots in other words
a bunch of the people now showing up as
getting doses
are already vaccinated to some degree
and that doesn't bode particularly well
for our path towards herd immunity so
that's not uh that's not good we talked
about ron desantis earlier this week and
matthew wrote in
and said hey david
why should we be scared of ron desantis
he seems like a regular corporate
republican not a trumpist at least when
i see him speak it's just regular
republican talking points not
necessarily trumpist things i'm sure if
he becomes president they'll disagree
with a lot of his policies and sure he's
an ass but why should we be scared he'll
destroy our democracy like trump did if
he became president i completely
completely disagree with matthew
ron desantis is a very trumpian
republican he has a lot of donald
trump's worst instincts to do the
opposite of what the science says on
kovid to push these big lies about
election fraud and he announced a few
weeks ago he's opening a commission or
something to investigate election fraud
it's like no
nobody trump won florida nobody's even
calling into question florida he is
bonkers out of his mind but
horrifyingly he is more competent than
donald trump so i completely disagree
that ron desantis is just kind of a
regular republican if you look at mitt
romney and ron desantis there's very
little in common
very very lo not i'm not praising mitt
romney i'm just stating a fact there is
no comparison between desantis and real
non-trump republicans like mitt romney
uh
the late john mccain
the late colin powell and others and
we've got to be very very scared if ron
desantis is the 2024 nominee
aaron says about kyle rittenhouse kyle
is a depreciating political commodity
regardless of the trial outcome kyle is
a depreciating political commodity that
will end up worthless after his two
weeks of fame are over he will never
have a substantive career one google
search will destroy his chan any chance
he has of making anything of himself
well unless it's in right-wing media and
right-wing agitation i do agree that
after the not guilty verdicts from last
week
rittenhouse is definitely getting his 15
minutes of fame appearing on fox news
being flown all around and he's
definitely getting some fame right now
i do agree that in terms of getting a
normal job working as if he ever
actually becomes an emt or whatever it
seems he's got an uphill climb ahead of
him but
i wouldn't be shocked if britain house
ends up
being a successful firearms youtuber
i wouldn't be shocked if rittenhouse
ends up as a cpac speaker
in that space in that space i actually
think he probably does have a future now
that he's being lionized and being made
a hero out of but i do think that his
usefulness will be quite limited to that
um
and i'm curious to see
i mean by january how many people are
talking about him i don't know we're
gonna wait and see
jeremy wrote in and said hey david
can't joe biden use an executive order
to pass the original 3.5 trillion dollar
build back better plan regards jeremy no
my research is that he cannot and that
uh something like uh
the 3.5 trillion dollar buildback better
plan needs to go through congress it
relates to appropriating money and it is
not something that joe biden can do via
executive order i don't even know that i
need to say more about it because my
understanding is that cut and dry very
very simple and straightforward if
someone has a different perspective on
that could joe biden
implement elements of buildback better
through executive order maybe let me
know but no my research and we have
looked at it very strongly is uh you
can't pass build back better
via executive order and lastly today
chris wrote in and chris says thank you
this is just like a nice message we
don't get that many of these thank you
hey david i've been watching your show
for a while i very much appreciate what
you do
you've consistently been a voice of
reason in the left-wing space online it
hasn't gone unnoticed that you
understand how the type of content you
put out affects people in real life i
know it would be easy to grab more views
to put out a spicy fouchy video or cover
conspiracies but you understand that
only serves to create more doubt around
the effort to save lives i've had a few
people in my life pass away from covet
and all of them watched prominent
youtubers or online podcasters who were
quote only asking questions about covid
and the coveted vaccines you care about
your audience and we can see it your
work is invaluable thank you chris thank
you
i really appreciate that
and um you know it can be very easy to
focus on like the first email that i
showed you disgusting anti-semitism
directed
specifically at me
uh and it's great to hear from chris i
really appreciate that remember that we
are going to be off tomorrow thursday
for thanksgiving and friday for
thanksgiving we will then be back on
monday federal thanksgiving holiday here
in the united states everybody taking a
much needed break and he will be back
with you monday but before that there's
the bonus show if you're a member at
joinedpakman.com
sign up at joinpakman.com you can get
access to the bonus show
otherwise we'll see you back here on
monday
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman